Welcome back, everyone.
It's Charlie.
HBO just released The Last of US Season
two teaser to announce
that they've renewed the show.
Neil Druckman has talked a lot
about their plans
for what they're going to be doing
with the story for season two.
So we'll break it all down.
If you're brand new to the channel,
I'm doing videos for all the episodes,
be sure to subscribe to get them.
We're also doing a giveaway
for HBO Max subscriptions.
All you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber
and let me know what you want them to do
in season two.
Please don't post a bunch of spoilers for
what happens during the Last of US two.
There's a lot of people
that haven't played the game yet
and careful for spoilers for everything
that's happened on the show so far.
I'm not going to go too
deep into the story of the game
just because of me posting this video.
Only two episodes have aired so far
and there are a lot of people out there
that never played the games
and are just seeing this all happen
for the first time on the show.
But if you haven't played the games
I've talked about this
in my previous episode videos,
but the show is basically following the
games pretty closely with a few changes.
There might be some bigger changes in
later episodes that we haven't seen yet,
but mostly it's following the games
they're currently to Last of US games.
Neil Druckman actually recently started
talking about The Last of US three,
and they're also in the middle
of making The Last of US multiplayer game,
which is like additional characters
and breaking news story.
So there is theoretically way more
additional canonical material
for them to adapt for the show.
But this is what Neil Druckmann said about
Last of US three
just because that would be like
the next logical place
for the story to pick up in future seasons
after they finish the story.
Part two
He says Our process is the same thing
we did when we did part two,
which is
if we can come up with a compelling story
that has universal message
and statement about love
just like the first and the second game
did, then we will tell that story.
If we can't come up with something,
we have a very strong ending with part two
and that will be the end.
I think he's just pulling the taffy
a little bit with that because a lot
of the people who made the Last of US
to game, particularly Neil Druckmann,
said that they regret revealing
that they were making the game so early.
Fans found out that they were making
the second game relatively
soon after them releasing the first game.
Usually studios
wait a bit longer before they reveal that.
So I think with the show hitting so big
and being so popular in season one so far,
they just want to wait
a little while longer before they say,
Oh yeah, by the way,
we're going to be doing
The Last of US three.
There'll be way more story,
four more seasons after that.
But based on the two games
that they currently have,
they said that Season one
is meant to cover the entire story
of just the first game
and they plan on breaking up the story
of the second game the last of US
two across multiple seasons.
They could break it into two seasons.
They could break it into three seasons
if they wanted to,
because the story of the second game
is so much bigger than the first.
They're basically doing for the Last of us
what they did for House of the Dragon
in George R.R. Martin's Game of Thrones
universe.
House of the Dragon is meant to be
just the story of the Targaryen family
taken from his Fire and Blood book.
But the events of the first prequel show
like The House of the Dragon episodes
I've been doing videos
for, is just for the Dance of the Dragons
in all the book material
for that only covers a couple of short
novellas with very little actual book
material
compared to what they had to adapt
for the original Game of Thrones episodes
with the main
a Song of Ice and Fire novels.
So what they've been doing
with House of the Dragon
and what they've also started to do
during the Last of US Season one,
is they've greatly expanded on moments
from the original story, so they get way
more episodes and seasons out of it.
Really good examples of this
during the Last of US
Episode three is meant to primarily
be a bill and frank episode based on just
that next part of where the story picks up
after episode two in the Games.
Right after Joel and Ellie escaped Boston
during that part of the story in the game,
they were just going to Bill's
to find a car that would take them
to Joel's brother's settlement in Wyoming
so we could check and see if he was okay,
because Tommy used to be a firefly.
Joe also thought that he could help
Ellie find the rest of the fireflies
who theoretically be able to use her
to create a vaccine for the fungus.
There were a couple events
during that part of the game,
but all in all, in the game, the encounter
with Bill doesn't really last that long,
and it's mostly
just a short series of missions
going around collecting parts
for an old car bills
to try and get it to start
so they can continue their quest
in all of their scenes with Bill
are very brief in comparison,
but on the show, no spoilers
because of me posting this video.
The episode hasn't aired yet,
but on the show
what they did is make a bunch of changes
and had a whole series of flashbacks
in episode three to explain Bill
and Frank's backstory
that covers most of the episode.
In the actual episode is extra long.
Normal episodes are around 45 minutes,
like episode two was a little bit shorter,
even though it was meant to be
a relatively normal length.
People are just expecting super
long episodes all over the place now.
Episode three is a full hundred
and 15 minutes more like episode one,
like a short movie.
They also changed a bunch of Bill
and Frank's backstory for the episode too,
in the things that happened to them
in the way that Bill interacts with Jill.
But it is a massive improvement to what
the story from the original game was.
The bigger, expanded, slightly different
version they did on the show was amazing.
Estere And for anyone who has seen
the story of the second game, Last of US
two or even just seeing some of the game,
this bodes extremely
well for future seasons.
While everyone loves the story
of the first game, we're seeing that play
out over season one. It's an amazing game.
They actually say after the first couple
of episodes,
sales of that first game spiked big time.
The last of us to game was extra
really controversial in comparison.
People either loved it or they hated it,
and people who hated it really hated it.
It was extremely polarizing.
But here's why.
All the changes
they're making during season
one make me way more hyped for season
two and beyond.
Because if they can make
the original story of the first game
so much better with all their changes
and expansions on certain characters,
they can do the same thing for season two.
Without getting into spoilers.
There's a moment during the Last of US two
about 30% of the way through the game.
It's a huge WTF moment
and one of the best places for them to end
season two, depending on how fast
they want to blow through the story
so they can get even more than two seasons
out of the second game if they want to.
The entire story of that second game
is way, way longer than the first one,
which is why it's so easy for them
to break into pieces.
A lot of the themes are the same as season
one, like Neil Druckmann
talks about The Last of US three.
Like as long
as the same themes continue to
and we can find a good story,
we will make the last of us. Three.
It continues to be about people
trying to survive, find redemption,
forgiveness and love amidst
the fungus, the apocalypse.
There is a five year time jump
between the end of season one
and what will probably be
their starting point in season two.
In the young actress playing
La Bella Ramsay,
she was on the original Game of Thrones
series with Pedro Pascal, too.
They even talked about it recently,
I assume,
from the Game of Thrones world,
which you bring to The Last of US.
I really loved my robe.
I did say this.
Why is it clothing telling you?
What about you?
I liked my armor from season eight.
Yeah, They didn't
actually share any scenes together
because she played the little Bear.
Lyanna Mormont in Pedro
Pascal played Oberyn.
Martell in his character
was only in season four and never visited
the North, so the characters never had
any reason to have scenes together.
But Ellie is meant to be about
14 during the events of season one,
and she'd be 19 when season two picks up.
Unless they move the timeline a little bit
and I'm not expecting them to do that.
They did add a couple of extra flashbacks
during episode one one to the 1960s
at the beginning with the scientists
talking about the potential
for the cordyceps fungus
to become a threat.
Then another much bigger version
of Joel's backstory to explain
how everything happened,
how he got to Boston
so they might do something
similar at the beginning of season
two with them or with other characters.
A five year time
jump leaves a lot for them to cover.
But in real life, Bella
Ramsay is 19 right now.
They filmed season one last year,
so she would only been 18
when all these scenes were happening.
Even though she looks like a little girl,
she has this very petite, childlike
look about her.
It's way easier for them
to use some minor makeup effects
to make her look like an older teenager.
They've been using her costumes
and makeup to each her down
just a little bit for season one.
She already looks kind of
like a little girl, so it's not that hard.
This was Neil Druckmann and Naughty Dogs
playing for Ellie in the video games, too.
She was voiced by Ashley Johnson,
who voices a lot of very young,
very petite characters.
But her actual physical character
model was based on Ellen Page,
now called Elliot Page.
But that was more than ten years ago
when they made that first game.
And at the time Ellen Page
had a very childlike appearance.
The funny thing is they didn't admit
this was the case, that they based Ellie
on her until a few years ago.
Like a long time went by before
they were public about it.
Like,
Oh yeah, that was meant to be Ellen Page.
But when the game was actually released,
fans noticed pretty quickly,
like, Oh,
Ellie looks a lot like Ellen Page.
If they ever make The Last of US series,
she should be played by Ellen Page.
The reason why she's not Ellie on the show
right now is because it took so long
for them to actually make the show
that she's now 35 years old
and she is Elliot Page.
This the real big thing
about the Last of US season two Right now,
fans are convinced that they discovered
HBO is casting Abby from the games
and it's going to be played by actress
Shannon Barry.
Neil Druckman recently
followed her on Instagram.
Craig Mazin, the showrunner, hasn't yet,
but he barely follows anyone in.
The actress just followed
Pedro Pascal, Bella Ramsey, Neil Druckman
and the official Last of US account
on her Instagram.
If you remember, actors do dumb stuff
like this on social media all the time.
Inadvertently revealing
casting information.
Jamie Fox famously did it for Spider-Man
No Way Home
the year before the movie came out,
when we were all still guessing
that Andrew Garfield,
Tobey Maguire in the Sinister
Six characters from their movies
were coming back.
Jamie Foxx's
casting was announced publicly,
but they didn't say who he was playing in
at the time.
The trades dropped the news,
he posted a couple Spider-Verse fan
art pictures on his Instagram
with all three Spiderman in Electro.
So everyone was like,
This feels like confirmation
that Tobey Maguire, Andrew Garfield
are definitely coming back.
And it had been a rumor up to that point.
He quickly deleted the Instagram post
and then joked about it during press
for the movie. Like, Yeah,
I definitely gave that away.
So fans are just convinced that
something is going on with the Last of US.
Season two.
In Abbi's casting, she's a very important
character during season two,
without getting into spoiler
territory in her storyline,
how she gets involved
with the main characters,
it would be one of the key places
for the show to make some changes
from the original game story
and expand on it greatly.
Lots of room for improvement
with Abby's storyline right now
based on when they start filming
the last of US season two,
they wouldn't be able to release it
until the end of next year or early 2025.
It takes them a little over a year
to turn a season around now,
and it's the same problem
that they have with House of the Dragon.
House of the Dragon Season
two just started pre-production.
They're going to be filming
for most of this year.
They won't be releasing it
until summer of next year.
We're still in the middle
of the Last of US
Season one episodes right now,
so I'll be doing my regular episode videos
for that every week.
But after the finale does air,
I will continue to do season two videos.
As we get more details and footage
just like I've been doing for House
of the Dragon Season two.
I've already done
a bunch of House of the Dragon Season
two video, so I'll put links for those
in the description below.
And at the end of this, HBO
is usually pretty good about releasing
teasers and trailers for all the stuff,
and we get a lot of footage from the set
when they're filming My For Last of US
Episode three video
will post Sunday after they release it in
my Last of US episode four Trailer video.
We'll post after that.
Be sure to watch the episode
as soon as it drops.
It is going to be awesome.
Everyone post all your theories
about season two in the comments.
If you have any big questions or anything
you want me to address in future videos,
everyone click here for my Last of US
Episode three Video Update the link
As soon as I post that
and click here for my House of the Dragon
Season two Teaser Trailer Video.
Thank you so much for watching.